we are about to enter a whole new decade  of gaming the year 2020 is bringing us a  ton of anticipated games like the  long-awaited Final Fantasy 7 remake the  next chapter and Master Chief's story  with Halo infinite and the latest  projects from lauded developers like CD  Projekt RED and Naughty Dog just to name  a small few on top of that the next Xbox  and PlayStation consoles are launching  in the 2020 holiday season opening up a  whole new chapter in videogame history  so sit back relax and enjoy this look at  game spots most anticipated games for  2020 and beyond  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  holidays we need to run  no we need a fight  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]